[Music]
hi my name is Leon Botstein I'm
president of Bard College and I'm a
musician and a historian of music my
subject today are the arts and art and
what is it and why should we study it
why is it part of the university
curriculum why is it something that an
undergraduate student should worry about
and spend time taking courses in so the
first thing is to sort of think about
what the word means art is a is a word
we use all the time it is an ordinary
usage applied to lots of different
things and people get worried about you
know something is it artistic is it art
what distinguishes art from anything
else that you might encounter in the
world and pro the simplest way to say it
is that art is something that transforms
the everyday it transfigures the
ordinary so a good example and a very
soft clear example is in the period of
pop art the artist Andy Warhol - a
Campbell Soup can and made a work of art
out of something we looked at ordinarily
on the Shelf of a supermarket take a
photograph now you can take a photograph
with your cell phone you can look
through it and snap someone's picture a
question is is that art as opposed to a
great photographic portrait take for
example the great American photographer
Edward Steichen did a portrait of
Charlie Chaplin you look at that
portrait and you ask yourself is that
art or just a photograph of Charlie
Chaplin but there's something different
about it there's something unexpected
there's something that isn't quite in
your ordinary experience yet it's
related to ordinary experience another
example comes also from the pop art era
and that has to do we
comic books so the great artist Roy
Lichtenstein made big canvases where you
have the same kind of visual impact that
a comic book had people with bubbles
coming out their mouths with things
being said and things very much apropos
of what comic books talk about love loss
a kind of soap opera story so art is
connected to what we experience every
day but it represents some kind of
transformation of the everyday something
that is not actually entirely real it
can't be found by locating it
it requires human intervention it is the
fingerprint if you will of our existence
in the world that has its impact on
things we transform through the use of
our imagination it is always the case
that there is some aspiration some
insight something that happens in the
transformation of the everyday through
an artistic impulse that is entirely
human and therefore subjective there's
something that goes beyond the
thoughtless it goes beyond something
that we would pass by it makes us stop
and think about something quite
important in an entirely different way
it's for that reason that already from
the Greeks the notion that art making
was human was crucial it was something
like love that only mortals could
experience gods didn't make art but we
made art about the gods because our
capacity was limited by immortality but
yet our imagination which was distinctly
human which was our own impression of
the world with very limited knowledge
and limited capacity the way we escaped
that limitation was through an imaginary
world which we could create the same way
we escaped our limitation of being
mortal by imagining ourselves to be in
love and create a category we call love
so a good example would be to say music
which is perhaps one of the most easy
aspects of art to talk about now music
doesn't exist really in nature birds
sing and there's birdsong and their
sounds in nature but the system of
Indian or Chinese or western music how
we divide tones how we organize them the
west by half steps and whole steps
sometimes with micro tones and we
organize rhythm we create a grammar of
sound and expectation so a song like row
row row your boat is something that
seems natural to us we can identify when
it starts and when it ends we have a
pretty good idea of how its organized
now that's totally artificial there's no
roar you roll your boat song out in
nature and there certainly isn't
anything as complicated as in the
Western tradition a Beethoven symphony
or even an opera which is very
artificial in which people are singing
and talking and moving at the same time
saying different things all within a
coherent fabric this is completely
fictive it doesn't have a real place in
the world even when we try to be
realistic go to a museum and you look at
a painting genre painting or historical
painting which depicts a scene that you
think is really quite realistic someone
is fighting a battle a person is looking
out a window or you're looking at a
landscape which you actually perhaps
have seen yourself but that frame is
very artificial and we allow ourselves
be caught up in the illusion of its
realism it isn't really out there it
isn't real it's somebody's imagination
of what is real the perfect example is
TV video and film where we get caught up
in a storyline that may take years and
centuries it seems real to us the whole
thing that's only an hour and a half
long but it has the illusion of realism
and that is the artificial manipulation
of our sensibilities through the work of
an artist
all the transformations I've described
the creation of music or the creation of
an artificial visual image are things
that people do regularly in things that
don't always qualify as art so we can
choose people who design boxes or
packaging for products or people even do
fashion design although that's that's a
contentious area and people who write
jingles or commercial music or
soundtracks for TV shows now is that art
now there's always a lot of debate
particularly among snob about what is
art I think they know I'm sorry
and they confuse art with taste it's
hard to talk about we are not sure what
causes art is simply a matter of what I
think is art or someone else thinks is
art but it's quite clear that there's a
continuum well here we go a category of
things we call artistic or very often a
word that's used with art the beautiful
because we think conventionally that art
is about the beautiful and when we talk
about beauty people get very concerned
about it because one person's beauty is
another person's ugliness there are
people who think well you think it's art
but it means nothing to me and then
there's the notion that really great art
is often misunderstood because it
reaches beyond the conventional judgment
of most of the people so art often gets
pegged at being something quite elitist
most people don't think it's art so for
example in abstract art when people
began to make paintings have seemed the
only one color or very simple shapes or
Jackson Pollock two things with swirls
of color that people look at thought
well that I can do that that's like
finger painting my child can do that
well there's something about a child's
finger painting that may actually not
qualify in our view as art not because
if the prejudiced but because actually
there's something different between a
finger
of a child and what Jackson Pollock does
one of the important things about what
makes a work of art is the power of the
human imagination to predict something
although there have been strong
traditions of art that are random people
who believe in randomness or in
happenstance or in chance most of what
we think is art is the result of people
thinking about doing something and being
carried away by either some plan or some
intuition or some imagination so the
child's finger painting is probably
distinguishable from Jackson Pollock by
its structure its composition its intent
it's designed
[Applause]
[Music]
art is really the attempt to create
through time and in space a work or
statement or an event that has some
coherence that derives from is connected
to everyday experience but it's really
quite apart from it and works back in
our experience of it to that everyday
experience it creates a vocabulary of
sensibility a vocabulary of
interpretation a vocabulary of meaning
that in one sense is beyond that of
language very important about art is
that it is not restricted to language
there is art and language we see that in
poetry which is a different use of
language the use of language in many art
forms visual architectural and in music
but much of art and much of the art that
we care about responds to something
other than the linguistic we talk about
in language about our experience of it
is somehow a round language it bypasses
language many philosophers have argued
that the visual and particular musical
reaches an individual in a different way
not through the medium of language and
therefore it's not entirely rational not
something that we can say is right or
wrong when we say we're moved by work of
art or that were inspired by work of art
we often find it hard to put that in
words the power of music for example is
best expressed in the way music
interacts with words so take a great
moment in the operatic literature in
Mozart's Marriage of Figaro at the very
end it's a opera about infidelity and at
the very end
the countess forgives her husband
account for contemplating if not
realizing infidelity she realizes the
loss of love so as she forgives
account the music which has no words to
it tells an inner story to the audience
of a sense of loss a sense of distance
from what she's actually saying that
would be impossible to communicate
without music much of art is public art
hangs in museums their installations
there's public art and the most
important public art of all is
architecture
what do buildings tell us about
ourselves if you look at a fabulous
building for example the Helsinki
railway station by a lil Saarinen
fabulous building massive showing the
public the entire nation the modern
Finland embodied by the Train so it's a
massive train station similar to many
that is in Europe but it has a slight
difference
it speaks to its public by making it
much lower and flatter so the
relationship of the individual to the
massive of the railway station is not
imposing it's not a one of tyranny it's
non one of superior power
it doesn't celebrate industrial power it
doesn't celebrate wealth and in fact it
is much more intimate despite its scale
furthermore if through it there are
decorative elements which remind the
user of an imaginary traditional finland
of a finland of the Kalevala of a mythic
past of a tradition of a nation that was
distinct from the rest of europe so
local pride folklore national identity
all get communicated through art making
things are completely artificial you
don't need to have that kind of railway
station just to put no trains in place
it could be a much more neutral if you
will a solution to how to build a
railway station the capital of the
United States is an architectural
statement that reveals ideals about what
the builders thought the American
Republic was going to be about
so art is a public endeavor often that
takes place in public spaces it's also a
private endeavor it informs how we
organize our private space and what how
we use it in days when people were
amateur musicians and sang and played
together that was a form of a
conversation people sat down to a place
during quartet and that was a
conversation with for people that use no
language just music people sang together
in their parlors people went to choruses
in church or in secular circumstances to
see them together so art is not only the
enterprise of the individual art maker
or the individual person who seeks to
transform his or her experience of the
everyday by something that is not real
but transformed by a human being called
art but they also have to recognize that
art is about the way we live our laws in
a public circumstance when one
recognizes that art is not merely an act
of an individual who exceeds his or her
boundaries of experience in ways we
cannot predict parenthetically it's
important to realize that art is never
something that has to exist in science
we have the notion that what we discover
is something that somehow was out there
now that's not totally entirely true the
way we describe it our conception of
nature and of the world and the laws of
nature effects how we understand it and
use it but there is a correspondence
theory there's some evidence we have to
show that the way we describe it the
theories that we have describe it
actually are true and there's some
evidence so there was a great deal of
speculation and relief when relativity
was proven by astronomical observation
by sort of experimental evidence now in
art what is created has no reason to
exist it wasn't out there before a human
being made it
which is why art is so significant to
the individual because it is a reminder
both for the maker of the art and the
person who engages with the art of his
or her uniqueness in the world you know
we would like to think which is true
that each of us has a fingerprint that
is unique and a DNA sequence that's
unique which is why we can be identified
if we commit a crime but by the same
token the making of art is a reflection
of that uniqueness which has no
predictive content when you hear a piece
of music a new piece of music written by
a composer or you see a work of art and
installation performance art movie any
photography that one sees one realizes
this is the imagination of a single
individual whose existence could not
have been foretold so there's a kind of
uniqueness that uniqueness has the
parallel in the viewer
no artwork is complete unless it has
someone who receives it when there's no
one in the museum the real purpose of
art dies those works come alive through
the presence of a viewer a piece of
music exists only if it's played and
heard and therefore requires human
intervention the important thing about
that is art is one way particularly in
our current society to fight the sense
of being superfluous one had to ask in
contemporary life what is the most
important aspect of art to the
individual is the recognition that in a
very large mass society in which most of
things we do are governed by efficiency
we can make things with robots we
actually produce
dude immensely efficiently and with the
promise of biotechnology and information
science slightly that those efficiencies
will only increase so there are a lot of
people in the world what are we here for
we once thought the primary reason for
our existence was labour we were here
because we had to where to till the soil
we had to protect ourselves from
external danger rain snow weather we had
to take care of the necessities of life
and by so doing we had to something
useful and that useful thing could be
rewarded rewarded either in money which
was a much later system or in actually
goods which would feed us and our
children but that notion of work in
labor is increasingly at risk while we
would like to see all of our society
very well employed one could posit a
future where we are not needed where you
know there's an easy pass for every
function you don't need a toll collector
anymore you need an elevator operator
you don't need a manufacturing person
you don't need an artisan so what are we
here for well we're probably here for
the things that are not useful we're
here for the things that have no utility
that have no purpose that are simply
about our life and that essential sense
of our purpose being what we can do that
may have no practical utility that sense
of the sacred character of our capacity
to create if one believes the abrahamic
tale that we were made in God's image
what does that mean means that God was a
creator he used language to create well
we also use language great but we also
have the capacity for creation for
imagination and the things that we
imagine often fall into the category of
art things that don't exist things we
put together things we completely rely
on our fantasy our humor
our sense of joy our sense of
possibility and our sense of the thing
that wouldn't ordinarily occur if we
just lived our lives in some predictive
way in some imitative way which is why
art can be dangerous because it doesn't
follow rules rarely follows rules but
the important thing about art both in
its making and its absorption its
engagement is we reinvent ourselves we
invent ourselves in our relationship to
listening to music in in many
circumstances people who find their
lives transformed by looking at a
beautiful building or a work of art or
even a movie or young people who will
swear by a series of popular songs that
seem to be very meaningful to them that
identification with the imaginary which
helps us define ourselves in some unique
way the way we put it all together the
mosaic of our own tastes those things
allow us to give ourselves purpose where
we could be very depressed by a sense of
uselessness and boredom the most
terrifying thing is the loss of life and
the sense of purpose by boredom and that
creates envy and hostility to others we
envy the person who seems to be useful
and needed we're looking for a safe
place where we can feel ourselves
important and significant this is why
many of us choose to join religious
communities or other communities where
through some community identification we
give ourselves purpose but art allows us
as individuals to have a purpose as we
make it participate in it consume it if
you will engage with it and it reminds
us of narcho passive create art but to
recognize it and follow someone else's
imagined imagination along with him or
with her now the social utility of art
the fact that it's public the fact that
it's pretty Universal in the sense that
most societies create some kind of
some of it the social utility has been a
subject of enormous controversy there
are people who think precisely because
art is imaginary in some way it isn't
real and it isn't useful in some way
he's a kind of Mirage that distorts our
sense of value famously Plato had his
doubts about poetry and about certain
kinds of art making there's a long
tradition of suspicion that art first of
all is a conceit among a very small
group of human beings who try to make
themselves superior through a kind of
Ponzi scheme of values that they they
all inhabit and they exclude other
people from it's a Ponzi scheme because
it really has no value at the end of the
day this notion of art is particularly
prevalent in democratic societies which
is why for example the United States
there is really no public subsidy of the
Arts because people will say look you
think it's art I don't Lee its art and
these artists are not really useful why
should we support them and art is really
a matter of taste so it's no different
from clothes buying you know classical
music is so important should pay for
itself and people like it should buy it
people like that painting on the wall
they want to pay five million dollars
for it you know I'm just as happy with a
ten cent poster I can buy down the
street who's gonna tell me that Norman
Rockwell the famous illustrator is
somehow inferior is an artist to sums of
strange thing that's on someone's wall
in Southampton who believes her himself
to be a real connoisseur and collector
and spent four million dollars for
something I wouldn't give ten cents for
so in a Democratic Society
the majority wins which means what we
might think is art perfectly reasonably
is Hollywood makes money or Broadway on
the off
it makes money and many of the
non-commercial arts are considered it's
a conceit of a minority it's one's own
private religion and that met in mass
society in mass democracy there's no
agreement about what is art and it's not
real much agreement whether art is
necessary in our society no it's totally
seemingly
persuasive it actually is hypocritical
because the government builds buildings
so it chooses architects makes it
absolute statement in what kind of
architecture chooses but beyond that the
nation you know in its military has
orchestras and bands it recognizes that
art is part of the fabric of a community
it has always been part of the fabric of
what we consider patriotism the songs we
sing our National Anthem it's not so
easy to say well there's no art and
there's also not so easy to say that you
know it's only those things that make
money because in fact all true things
are not popular evolution is not popular
maybe true but it isn't popular and
there are many facts which are not
pleasant but are true and hard to
understand the earth is not flat we all
operate as if it is now it's very
complicated to explain to some of that
it's round but the fact that that's true
and it's only understood by minority
doesn't make it wrong now the real
debate in the arts is are there criteria
for art that could be persuasive in a
democratic society to induce a society
to support it is there some objective
way of saying well a Beethoven symphony
of ogner Opera a Debussy Nocturne those
are superior to something else that
certain building certain painters
certain sculptors are
understood is critically superior to
things that are the same type but not as
good
is there a hierarchy of goodness is
there some truth value to our judgments
about art is it reasonable to say well
that just isn't art or is not very good
art or bad art if we could make those
discriminations and we might create a
hierarchy of value where then we could
justify Society supporting it in
monarchies and our store credit
societies arts were supported by patrons
and the patrons happen to be the state
in the case of kings and queens emperors
and in certain eras between the
Communist era the Party and the state
had a very clear idea of what was art
that was good for the state fascists had
the same idea both Hitler and Stalin
were art lovers and there were music
lovers and then very very specific
tastes in Stalin's case he hounded
Shostakovich twice in his career in the
30s in the 40s for riding music that
wasn't right that wasn't really towards
what art should do in the community now
those were not necessarily aesthetic
criteria there were political criteria
if you couldn't separate the two for a
moment they were about what made people
feel part of a working class communist
proletarian nation or how music should
that sound like what kind of painting
should that be let's call it socialist
realism in fascism was a clear idea of
how to portray the Aryan purity and the
Aryan race and Nordic superiority and
music like Carmina Burana
very famous piece that was designed give
people a sense of membership and
solidarity that manipulated people's
emotions so it was consistent with
objectives in the state but that's not
about the truth value that's about a
regimes belief and how art actually can
function to help that regime so to
return to the question particularly for
the United States in a democratic
society we don't support the art
because we can't agree as to what would
be our we can agreed what it makes a
profit so if you want to do art and you
can pay for it everyone's happy
people can go to it but why should we
subsidize opera companies museums
artists performance spaces independent
filmmakers and photographers why do that
why not leave it simply to the
marketplace and one way to solve that
problem would be to say well as in
science there can be a kind of
peer-review objective sense of what is
good what is bad and if we could
discriminate who could agree then we
could say well these people deserve
support these people don't clearly the
more you think about each separate art
form movies films buildings music
painting sculpture performance art you
develop sensibilities criteria there was
a great example for example in the case
of the composer Mozart he had a pupil
Thomas Atwood who became a court
composer in England during the reign of
Victoria he was a fine musician but not
a great talent perfectly fine crafts
wrote a fair amount of music none of
which has survived but it's very
competent nice music is is art music
it's it's it's fine it's good it's
interesting it's historically
interesting because every age has its
own artistic currents and it's very
interesting to understand the past art
is a terrific instrument for getting
under the skin so to speak of ever past
era now Thomas Edward studied with
Mozart now my start was not much of a
teacher he did it only for the money and
the strange thing about Thomas Atwood is
that it's the one complete record
because he was English and very
meticulous he kept his lessons with
Mozart it's the only record we have of
Mozart teaching he gay
at would lessons and exercises and it's
a great example of a minuet dance in
which he gave Atwood a baseline and
asked him to fill it out you got one
line you had to fill it out give melody
so I gave him a bass line a kind of
Foundation which to write the minuet
dance in three meter and the fascinating
thing is when Mozart was correcting it
he made slight changes and if you play
Atwoods exercise that he gave back to
motor and Mozart's just to fill the time
their thing about it
editing and changing of it you see the
difference between the ordinary and the
great and blindfold and audience who's
listened to a lot of eighth century
minuets will identify the Mozart one
right away
so there are many such examples where
actually works of art and music catch an
imagination or seem to appeal to some
criteria of craftsmanship perhaps even
beauty imagination novelty surprise when
things about art is that it breaks your
expectations unlike a train ride where
you'd be shocked if there were a sudden
stop or if suddenly it turned upside
down
and kept moving or as in all those Harry
Potter films you could levitate and go
into an imaginary place with some wand
well art is like that to the human
experience
it sets up expectations and then changes
them you think you're going down one
road you go to another you think
something's gonna happen regularly and
then it just stops happening regularly
you think well it's gonna look like this
and doesn't it makes you look at the
world around you in a different way
well the unexpected comes in varying
degrees of sophistication and so in
every art form there are criteria that
have been developed that are both
historical and go beyond historical
periods where we can discriminate from
the more persuasive the less persuasive
to some degree of agreement and then it
deviates because the judgment of history
isn't always right we rediscover artists
that we never thought much of bring them
back a good example would be for example
the Austrian painter Gustav Klimt when
the 50s was not an important figure but
by the year 2000 was a very important
figure even though he had died in 1918
there was a great Hungarian painter of
mukaichi hugely patronized by Americans
and by Europeans a forgotten figure now
but in his lifetime highly touted the
most expensive canvases to be sold
before 1904 by the Swiss German painter
Arnold
after that his importance of almost
vanished he now is experiencing a
revival
so tastes change and judgments change
and you cannot always rely on the
so-called verdict of history because
there are many political and other
factors that go into a person's success
or failure but there are areas of
discussion where one can look at a novel
a poem a painting a building a movie and
say this is a great movie and that's why
and many of those things are separate
from the content of the movie itself or
the painting or nomally the piece of
music these are things we call formal
and those are criteria of construction
the use of the materials the use of
space and time their criteria of the way
conventions of storytelling or
construction are used by the individual
artist so there are ways we can
discriminate at the very end much of it
is subjective but there are many many
areas where great human achievements do
require some more sophistication in the
way we read the way we look and the way
we listen it can't all be naive at first
blush a Mahler symphony doesn't seem
comprehensible how can actually sustain
one's attention over 75 minutes of just
the sound but then as one sort of
listens to it and goes back and listen
to a Beethoven symphony in a Hyden
symphony a Mozart symphony and the
Mendelssohn symphony even a Sibelius
symphony of contemporary you then get an
idea of what the possibilities are the
first movie you see well you've never
seen another movie you see a lot of
movies you've been to discriminate not
only by the narrative or the subject
matter but by something about the form
of the movie the way movies are made or
can be made or might be made the same
with photographs
Vendrell you can look at your own
photograph that you took of your friend
or your parents or your sibling with
your camera in your cell phone and
realize it isn't quite the same as a
portrait by Irving Penn or Diane Arbus
there's something about what they did
with the same basic medium that shows
you that there's something you might
learn you might think about you might be
able to do it yourself
the question that we face increasingly
is to what extent in a democratic
society or any society particularly in
what we might call open or free
societies should we encourage the
development of the aesthetic
sensibilities of our citizens to what
extent should art be encouraged is part
of what we foster in the conduct of both
private and public life is art a
constructive constituent activity art
making art viewing our buying is the
artistic conversation if you will an
important part of what we would like to
see in our society is it consistent with
values such as freedom and justice now
these are once again topics that have a
long history of philosophical and
political debate it's important to say
that in unfree societies in societies
where there has been enormous amount of
censorship and repression art has
usually been an avenue of dissent that
is the the place of last resort
once speech pamphleteering public
political activity was banned and
restricted the last refuge of freedom
ended up being the arts poetry
particularly arts that were not
representational their group of arts
that are close or closer to nature they
might be painting photography film which
trade on the illusion of realism and
fiction prose fiction and then there are
those that are less tied to nature
seemingly that's poetry which doesn't
really use language in the ordinary
sense and then there's music clearly
which seems entirely abstract the most
abstract perhaps of the arts and those
become the most resistant to effective
censorship and therefore art can be
identified with courage and with
breaking the habit to conform especially
if conformity is associated with tyranny
we simply go about our business while
some people are harmed killed oppressed
exterminated and we are beaten into
submission and the resistance that
submission can often be the Arts by the
same token arts can serve the state and
they can be used to justify tyranny
search for coffee if the Russian
composer who returned to live under
Stalin wrote a cantata for Stalin's
birthday
or a visa for his health whose text is
unimaginable praising Stalin for every
good thing even the rising of the Sun
and the health of children
now this fawning to one of the most evil
people in in recorded history doesn't
make an advertisement for the virtue of
the arts per se
interesting about the Arts of course is
that while they may even be created to
serve a particular political purpose and
they are also susceptible to being
reinvented one of the best examples is
again for music is the ninth symphony of
Beethoven which has final movement whose
text is by the German poet Schiller and
it's nominally about human Brotherhood
and so called the ode to joy' but it was
performed on a regular basis by the
Nazis to celebrate Hitler's birthday and
to celebrate the heroes of the 1941
attack on Russia and was also used to
celebrate the fall of Berlin wall two
completely opposite political purposes
using the same music it resists
appropriation partly because music has
never been useful and therefore to be
taken into a purpose that's useful since
it's useless by definition it never
quite fits it doesn't fit as a
constituent element in somebody scheme
entirely persuasively but the question
in a free society or one where highly
fluid in terms of what we individuals
can do especially a consumer society
where we in a way like to think of our
freedom mostly is freedom of movement
where we can go and what we can do using
money as a metaphor of movement so there
was a great American artist Barbara
cougar who had a painting with sort of a
spoof on the Cartesian phrase I think
therefore I am
instead she had I
therefore I am in other words the idea
that our self-identity is as consumers
[Music]
is art a useful instrument of criticism
constructive criticism to the conceits
of our society now that's a hard thing
because much of art in the United States
in our societies is patronized by very
wealthy individuals so it's odd to see
very wealthy individuals collect or
support art that has huge amounts of
social criticism so people living in big
houses and mansions my art that somehow
utilizes the suffering of others or
tries to point out injustice social
injustice there's something slightly
hypocritical about these uses of art and
artists who in visual arts make a lot of
money trading on the kind of sympathy of
the very wealthy and powerful for the
plight of the poor and underserved but
really do nothing about it so you'll go
to a play that shows the suffering of an
afro-american man and they feel ennoble
by having wept in the theatre at the
sight of the suffering portrayed on the
stage and they think they've done
something to advance that cause there's
not a lot of evidence that that's true I
don't have evidence that except for
making myself feel feel more noble
because my sympathies were in an
artificial context on stage or in a
movie with a protagonist who was somehow
disadvantaged while I was very
comfortable and advantaged in some way
that that emotional difficulty through
art is constructive the French
philosopher jean-jacques Rousseau argued
that that actually is the very opposite
that all art does is allow us to be more
complacent with injustice art criticized
in some aesthetic way all the evils of
human society artists are really the
worst servants of the state because they
dress up all that's bad in the world in
a way it makes it palatable and in fact
the conceit of my being superior by
being artists allows me the
to pull the shades in my window as I see
the injustice in the street it allows me
to exempt myself from a sense of social
responsibility because I'm superior and
there comes the whole conceit of the
artist the bohemian the person who
doesn't play by the rules who thinks she
or he is superior because they're
artists and therefore they're exempt
from having to do what we all have to do
which is somehow contribute to the world
around us and make the world better in
some constructive way
so it's not clear that just generically
art is constructive that art is always
about freedom always about individuality
it's always on the right side not
clearly so and that the values that it
puts forward are not always ones which
we would find totally defensible but the
important thing is to think about the
question as an activity and as a
repository of human achievement is this
something that needs to be fought for
and at the core of that question is is
there a relationship between what art
does and the good morally good ethically
good is there a connection as the 18th
century philosophers would have lied to
a who think was the case between the
good and the beautiful the Russian
writer Leo Tolstoy really said beauty
isn't the issue then in fact beauty is
the problem the art shouldn't be about
beauty art really should be about
community and about goodness and the
function of art is precisely to use the
imagination to remind us that we are all
the same the same as children of God in
his case a Christian God and a Christian
world but the fact is that he was
suspicious of individuality although he
was himself supremely an individual in
the individualistic sense and he was
very suspicious of art short of some
moral ethical purpose teacher morality
was kind of
instrument of religion and he was very
suspicious and was in a long line of
thinkers who held art in suspicion
because it separated some human beings
from others it was against the notion
that we're all created equal
there were all the same people now I
haven't think the army is very powerful
but requires an answer I'm not sure they
have the answer
art has some relationship to what is
good one things about that also has some
relation to what might be true art isn't
completely arbitrary because it comes
out of the human imagination and becomes
something that we then need to respond
to there are things about it which seem
to be susceptible to creating a
conversation among human beings that
advances the cause of what is good and
what might be true give an example in
the performing arts the great thing
about the Performing Arts is that
there's no object if there's no residue
you know a painting or a photograph or a
movie can be reproduced it never really
gets lost
now the original might get lost but
they're pictures of it and if you
preserve it it can last forever so we
can go to museums and look at artworks
that were made thousands of years ago
but the important thing is that the
where the truth and goodness comes in is
that in the performing arts it is only
there when it is performed and then in
the memory of the people who performed
and listened so the performing arts
not be standardized we now live at the
end of the age of recording the great
thing about the Internet is that it has
destroyed high fidelity recording how
people who used to know by records and
listen to them now you know we can
listen to these records but the mp3 file
or the digital file that we now use
doesn't sound particularly good but it's
sufficient for us when we're running or
we're sitting around but we realize when
we go to a real live concert whatever
form of music it is there's a kind of
visceral acoustic sensuality and we
realize something that was always true
that the work of music or the work of
theater is in its presence seeing that
actor up there seeing how she speaks
seeing her perspire seeing her act and
every night is different the performance
exists not on tape it exists only in the
viewers reading of that performance and
no to viewers reading that performance
is alike
therefore the arts have a fundamental
function in redeeming the sanctity of
every single human being and since we
believe that the sanctity of every
single human being is actually a true
belief and we think it's the right
belief that my recognition whether I'm
on stage or I'm in the audience that in
this specific time and this specific
place in some village in some city
outdoors indoors day or night that
musical performance that theatrical
performance that form of performance art
that concert was a moment in time that
can never be recaptured some time moves
in one direction and that it becomes a
constituent element of my memory the
sense of the commonality that human
experience is quite significant because
it transcends the most ordinary
experience in fear of birth and death
the fear of hunger the fear of pain
while we might think that that would be
sufficient to make us feel common with
our human beings the more sophisticated
our society becomes the more literate we
become the more instruments of
differentiation we accumulate the more
important things like art are to
recognize our interdependence and our
equality so I would argue that an
aesthetic sensibility deepens the
sanctity of life and insofar as you
deepen the sanctity of life you create
some potential of resistance against
violence and cruelty and against tyranny
now that's very optimistic and very
religious of me if you will and it's not
something that I can defend entirely by
evidence a good historian would demolish
my argument by saying you know all the
Nazis were music lovers the communist
elite were art lovers every second
two-bit dictator has been some kind of
art collector and even amateur artists
but I would say that that doesn't
disprove the possibility it does prove
that making of art is the reflection of
an exceptional amount of ambition and
courage people artists are more likely
than not at people with more of a drive
then it's probably healthy most artists
are in that sense slightly deviant the
same people are always in the audience
they're not the people that made the
pictures in the museum that people who
go to the museum and I have greater
respect for the audience and I have for
my fellow artists in terms of sanity and
perhaps even human kindness but the
activity itself
the recognition that were capable of it
has some kind of uncomfortable potential
not yet realized relationship to what we
might think is both true and good at the
18th century philosophers were not off
the mark our capacity to create
something that is not useful
that's only understood by mortals that's
only within the human experience and
that is beyond the provable and everyday
that's unpredictable that is the highest
praise we can give for being human
therefore the historical residue in all
cultures and histories of that impetus
and that impulse seems worthy of study
and it is deeply encouraging to our
sense of our own lives to look at the
works of the imagination in all their
forms whether it be the visual the
spatial the decorative the useful the
auditory or even the physical in terms
of dance and movement it was said and I
think plausibly so that in the
organization of his ideas and in the
presentation of his ideas Einstein in
the early part of the career was deeply
influenced by his musical sensibilities
who's a mediocre violin it's not a very
good one the school records we have are
not particularly complimentary and he
really never played very well and his
tastes were very limited but he really
loved the classical tradition which was
really hiding Mozart Beethoven and
Schubert and he liked really early and
mid Beethoven not more experimental late
Beethoven but it could be argued that
his notion of beauty and elegance in
scientific explanation had a lot to do
with a sense of proportion clarity
transparency and logic that was enhanced
by his musical sensibilities
and so looking at the history of art and
art making and then looking at what we
in our time would do as artists to put
ourselves in the imagination of the
artist is I think very good use of a
student's time my recommendation for
students would be not to be passive not
to take only art history or music
history or theatre history or dance
history but actually to do it the most
important thing about art is the
capacity to human being to make it so if
interested music don't just study it do
it sing play interested movement do
dance and movement interested in the
visual arts make visual art there's a
performance art do it want to make
movies make movies take photographs but
in a more sophisticated and more
disciplined way than with your with your
iPhone and cell phone it is the
cultivation of the ability to organize
the world in this way which will help
you in other ways this hidden secret of
the Arts is that they have collateral
utility so for example a student who
learns how to abstract an image in a
drawing class take a figure seated draw
that figure but make sure the figure
with boundaries touch all four sides of
the page a very hard assignment but the
analytical capacity to manipulate one
side and once to ask for abstraction is
hugely powerful as a skill in life - the
ability to write a Canon or song the
builder to play instrument to sing
to dance these are disciplines of body
and mind which have unexpected utility
in whatever one wishes to do it would be
a tragedy to go through a university
life without a deep engagement with the
arts it's one of the few things in a
university that in students experience
that has a lasting impact on the conduct
of adult life long after one graduates
so I encourage you and I thank you for
your time and for your interest
[Music]
you